[Music]
hi everyone my name
i'm a is
at boston children's hospital and also
harvard medical school
i'm co-advised by dr gabriel crayman and
dr
yuli rutishauser
the first i want to thank elaborate for
inviting me to present in this year's
neuroscience virtual conference and
today i want to show you some
interesting neurons we recently find in
humans that detect cognitive boundaries
to structure episodic memories
so before diving into the neural
responses we observed i want to provide
an overall pictures in terms of why
detection of the cognitive boundaries is
important and how this can potentially
influence our episodic memory system
as all we all notice that we experience
the word in continuous manners however
we remember our past experience as
discrete events
for example
for two hour movies we don't necessarily
remember it as string by frank phases
but instead we will
our brain will automatically segment it
into small events
and form overarching associations among
them
then the fundamental question becomes
what defines an event
on one hand theoretical frameworks has
been proposing that the transformation
from the continuous experience into
discrete mnemonic episodes is highly
relied on the detection of cognitive
boundaries
and on the other hand
experimental study in rodents have
showing neural responses associated with
spatial boundaries
so here you can see four border cells
reported in the new rodent studies which
fire extensively as marked in the red
colors here at the edge of this square
space which is also the physical walls
in this square space
now
some type of neurons fire repeatedly in
a great cell patterns
when the rodents are running around
exploring this square space
however when we're converting this
square space into a hairpin maze by
putting some physical walls
suddenly this grip firing pattern was
converted into repeated sub-maps with
the highest firing rate at the turning
point of this european maze so this
results are suggesting that neurons in
the rodents can signal the spatial
boundaries and they are capable of
capturing the geometric structure of the
space
then the next question is what do we see
similar neural responses in humans
and whether those neurons also respond
to the cognitive boundaries in the
non-spatial domains
and further whether the boundary
responses kind of reflect the subsequent
memory formation or retrieval
so to address all these questions we
developed a spatial we developed memory
tasks which consists of three different
stages
during encoding we presented a series of
clips to the subjects with no sound
and the key manipulation here is that
we're inventing different types of
cognitive boundaries into the clips
for the no boundary clips there's no
manual added it's just a continuous
movie shot
and for the comparison reasons we use
the middle of the clip as our virtual
boundary for the analysis
and for the soft boundaries it contains
typical hollywood style cuts
so it re the thought boundary refers to
the transitions from related events in
the same movie
and for the hard boundary clips we
manually made it by putting two
different clips from two different
movies together
so the hard boundary actually refers to
the event transitions to the unrelated
events
so after subject watch all the clips
which is in 90 total clips
we evaluate subject's memory of those
clips they have watched in two different
ways
during series definition we extracted
frames from the clips they have seen
during encoding as target frames and
also frames they haven't seen from the
clips which is the foil frames
then we instructed subjects determining
whether the frames presented is old
which they have seen before or new which
they haven't seen before
we also evaluate subject's memory of the
temporal order of the clips
so we extract the frames from the videos
they have seen before and presented side
by side to the subject
and ask the subject to determine whether
the left or the right frame appears
first in original clips they have seen
besides the binary choice we provided
here we also invented some measurements
of subjects confidence levels
and in total this experiment has
performed on 20 subjects which are
patients undergoing surgical evaluations
with drug resistant epilepsy
so first i will go through some behavior
results when found
in the same recognition task for the
thin recognition accuracy if we plot it
against the relative distance between
the target frame and its reason past
preceding boundaries
what we found is that for the frames
right after soft boundary and heart
boundaries are tend to be better
remembered than the frames that were
further away from the soft and hard
boundaries
and such distant effects was not
presented in no boundary conditions
and for the time discrimination task
which extracted the frames across
different boundaries presented to the
subject side by site and asked them to
determine which one occurs the first
if we plotting subjects behavior results
in terms of their accuracy reaction time
and confidence ratings
what we found is that subjects tend to
have lower accuracy rate
and tend to take longer response time
and also are less sure about their
responses when trying to recall the
temporal order information across two
frames that were originally separated by
a hard boundary in the clips
so it seems like there are some
trade-off effects of the boundary
inference on episodic memory systems
we are looking into the neural data
trying to find any associated neural
correlates the technique we are using is
the neural links atlas system which
providing high sampling rates and we
were using the hybrid electrodes from
adtech
as shown here in the schematic plot
there are microwires spreading out on
the tip of each electroshank
which provide opportunities for us to
record in single-unit activity and also
the local field potential signals
so the whole implantation procedure is
solely driven by the clinical needs
the patients will take a
pre-implantation mri scan first
and the neurosurgeons and neurologists
will
will get the surgical planning based on
the clinical needs
and then they will inserted
macroelectrodes first and using the
electrode as a guidance to slide in the
microwires
and after the implantations
patients will get either a
post-implantation mri or ct
for help
better localize where the electrodes are
so on the top right you can see the
signals we recorded by using such
recording
particles now on the top row is the raw
signal you can already see some text on
top of the draw signals
which are
interactivity
and by applying the bypass filtering and
also using our open toolbox
o sort we were able to detect the spike
activities and group them together as
different clusters
across 20 subjects we recorded so far
we detect approximately a thousand
neurons across different brain regions
and for this study specifically we were
focusing on the medial temporal lobe
including the hippocampus medulla and
pure hippocampal drivers which have all
sodium supporting the episodic membrane
system in humans
as i mentioned before during the
encoding we presented different clips
embedded with different type of
boundaries to the subjects
so the first question is for the
recorded neurons we have how they
responded to this different type of
boundaries
so we plotted neurons responses against
different type of boundaries
and we found two different interesting
neurons
the first type we named as boundary
cells as shown in here is one boundary
cells we found
and each dot here represents the
activation of the neurons which is also
color coded for different boundary
conditions here
for boundary cells you can observe that
this neuron increase its fire rate after
soft and hard boundaries but doesn't
show any firing rate modulations before
or after the no boundary conditions
we also find another type of neurons we
name it as the event cells
and this is example event that we have
observed
so for event cells it only increases its
fine rate for the heart boundary
condition but not the other two boundary
types
of course across all the medial temporal
neurons we observed so far we have
detected 42 boundary cells and 36 event
cells
and they all show you very consistent
neuronal activity
for the boundary cells they all
responded to the soft and hard
boundaries and for the event cells they
only responded to the heart boundaries
one interesting question here is that
whether
the neural responses we observed to
associate with the boundaries is purely
driven by any visual transitions
since the no boundary doesn't have any
visual transition at all to address
these questions we also plotted the
neurons responses for all the boundary
cells and event cells when responding to
the clip onset
and also
as showing on the right side
these two group of neurons do not
respond to the clip onset clip offsets
the same way as they did for the
boundaries or for the soft and hard
boundaries
which suggests that
the observed boundary responses cannot
be simply explained by detecting of the
visual transitions but presumably
exporting or driven by high-level
covenant functions
another interesting information here is
that
since both boundary cells and vent cells
are responding to the hard boundaries
when we're plotting their responses
against the hard boundaries
we observed that the boundary cells
responds to the high boundary
approximately a hundred milliseconds
earlier than event cells
suggesting a hierarchical structure
might be preserved in the medial
temporal lobe and detecting the heart
boundary conditions
and interestingly the spatial
distribution of the boundary cells and
event cells are very localized
most of the boundary cells and event
cells are presented in the medial
temporal lobe including the medulla
hippocampus and pure hippocampal gyrus
regions
and on top of that most of the boundary
cells are located in the pure
hippocampal gyrus while the majority of
the event cells are in the hippocampus
so the next interesting question will be
whether the neural responses associated
with different boundaries also have some
inference or reflect certain subject
subsequent memory performance
to address these questions you will go
back to the original boundary cell i
showed you before
and this is the activation plot of that
boundary cell
if we further splitting into
splitting this
activation profiles
based on subject subsequent memory
performance in scene recognition whether
they get correct or incorrect
what we can see is that
the majority increased fine rate for the
soft and hard boundaries occurred in the
correct trials versus the incorrect
trials
and we further quantify such fire rate
modulations across all 42 boundary cells
consistently we see higher final rates
for the correct soft and hard boundary
trials compared to the incorrect ones
and we don't see such conditional
difference in the no boundary condition
then how about the event cells
for the event cells this is the same
cells i showed you before
such an activation plot we can also
convert it into a raster but into a
phase plot
by purely marking the spike in times of
each activation relative to the theta
phases
so then this activation plot will be
converted into a phase plot
with the x-axis still be the time zero
still be the time of the boundary and
y-axis becomes the phase
and we can further splitting this phase
plot based on subject subsequent memory
performance in the time discrimination
tasks
and then we observe that the spiking
timing of the uh
in the correct and
then we observe that the spiking timing
in the soft and hard correct trials tend
to clustered at specific phase
compared to the other four conditions
and we can further quantify this
clustering by using main resultant lens
computations
as shown in the screen line here
if the firing phase is uniformly
distributed we expect a
smaller main resultant length
as showing in the blue line here if they
all fire at consistent phase you're
expecting to have a larger mean
resultant length
across all 36 event cells we're seeing
larger
mean resultant lengths in the correct
soft and hard boundary trials compared
to the incorrect ones and we didn't
observe any conditional difference in
the no boundary condition
then besides the single
neuron activities we also look at at the
population level how the neural state
changes
across corresponding to the different
boundary conditions
to address this question
we constructed a neural dynamics matrix
by combining all the activity from all
india temporal cells we recorded across
the subjects during coding
and then we projected this high
dimensional neural activity into a low
dimensional space by applying the
principal component analysis methods
and on the right side you see the neural
state space constructing using the top
three pc component
and each dot in this plot representing a
neural state at the given time point
the black dot indicating when the
boundary occurs
and also the line thickness
increased across time
so for the no boundary conditions the
neural states entangle with each other
before and after the boundaries
however for the soft and hard boundaries
we do observe a large neural state shift
after the boundaries
we can further quantify
how this neural state looks like by
using the multi-dimensional
distance measurements the mdd
so on the right side consistent with the
plot on the left
we observe this neural state shifts in
both soft and hard boundaries but not in
the no boundary condition
and interestingly such magnitude of the
neural response shift in mdd also
correlated with our behavior data
if we quantify the magnitude using the
area under curve mdd within the one
second time window after boundaries
we observe that the a
area under curve mdd is positively
correlated with our scene recognition
accuracy but negatively correlated with
our time discrimination accuracy
this is also tied up with our previous
observed trade-off effects in the memory
performance
last but not least we also look at how
boundary shapes the memory retrieval
to address this question we computed the
correlation between the scene
recognition and encoding
for each subject we formed these specs
vectors
and computed the correlation between the
scene recognition and encoding at each
given time point
by applying a sliding window we ended up
will getting this correlation maps for
each
trials
with the warmer color denoting the
higher correlation coefficient and
colder color denoting the lower
correlation coefficient values
and we computed this for all the trials
and group them based on subject behavior
outcomes
whether the its correct target so they
correctly recognize the target as old
directly reject the foils as inc new
incorrect target they fastly recognize
the
target as new or incorrect foils they
fastly recognize the foil images as old
so for this subject we observed that a
higher correlation occurs after soft and
hard boundaries
for correct target and incorrect foils
such trend is very consistent across
subjects as well as we see in higher
correlation values after soft and hard
boundaries
in the correct target and incorrect foil
trials but not the other two conditions
so this is suggesting that the neural
state at the boundaries actually
reinstated during the memory retrieval
as well
so in summary
behaviorally we observe that the
boundaries enhance the recognition
accuracy
however the heart boundary actually
impairs the memory of the temporal order
at the single neuron levels we observed
78 neurons signaling different
boundaries in the medial temporal lobe
either they responded to the heart
boundary only or both soft and hard
boundaries
and interestingly the response strength
of these boundary cells in event cells
also correlates with subject's memory
performance
then at the population levels we observe
the neural state shift across boundaries
their magnitude is positively correlated
with same recognition accuracy but
negatively correlated with the time
discrimination accuracy
and last but not least the neural states
at the boundary reinstated during the
memory retrieval suggesting that the
boundary serves as the landmarks for the
mental time travel during memory
retrieval
before i closing the talk today i also
want to thank my pis and also our
brilliant colleagues from different
recording sites including toronto
western hospital cedars-sinai medical
center
boston children's hospitals
and our funding source the brain
initiative
and our lovely patient and also our
clinical teams
and i hope you enjoyed the talk and
thank you for your attention
you